Speaker 1: I have to play a video for you
today that is out of this world cringe.
This is giga
Speaker 2: cringe.
That's what the
Speaker 1: kids call it.
And it really shows us how sort of backwards,
like what counts as humor is completely backwards
in American right
Speaker 2: wing culture right now.
Speaker 1: But it also shows us hypocrisy,
and that's an important part of this as well.
So let me set it up for you.
There is a comedian, some say and comedian,
and I'm completely an historian.
I'm behind.
And comedian.
It cannot be comedian Jim Breuer.
He has become sort of a darling of the right
wing over his commentary about the pandemic
because he was on Tucker Carlson speaking
out against vaccine mandates.
He has moved shows around to try to
Speaker 2: circumvent vaccination
Speaker 1: requirements.
We had a clip of him making a total fool out
of himself on Tucker Carlson's show about
a month ago.
I have never found this guy funny.
I used to hear him on The Howard Stern Show
a decade ago, two decades ago, and I always
said, This guy is not funny.
I don't know why he's on.
I didn't know anything about his politics.
He has become even less funny
Speaker 2: and the material
Speaker 1: I'm about to play for you.
I watch this.
It gave me chills.
I had chicken skin
Speaker 2: from watching this cringe.
Speaker 1: So here's a clip of Jim Breuer,
and this counts as comedy for the American
Speaker 2: right wing folks,
Speaker 1: and he's sort of doing a bird impression.
Speaker 2: Now, hold on, hold on.
That could be funny.
Maybe?
I don't know.
Speaker 1: And the bird impression is to mock
people who pay attention to scientists, specialists
Speaker 2: and doctors rather than, I guess,
Speaker 1: right wing media figures and quacks.
And he does the bird impression while saying
things like Fauci science.
And for me, the notable part of this is there
have been unfunny comedians for a long time.
That's not new.
Speaker 2: The most notable part is that they
Speaker 1: pan to people in the audience.
This is at one of these Reawaken America events.
And people are just losing their
Speaker 2: minds, laughing,
Speaker 1: pointing, laughing.
They're in hysterics.
Do these people not get out of their house?
Speaker 2: And so for me, that says way more
Speaker 1: about the people who like this
stuff.
Brewer hasn't been funny for decades, but
the audience acting like this is the vanguard
of comedy is amazing.
So take a
Speaker 2: look at the video.
You know what a cockatoo
Speaker 5: is, cockatoo is.
And that's what everyone's become a little
cockatoos staring at the screen.
Facts and figures, facts and figures.
Dr. Bakshi.
Dr Fathi.
I trust the science.
The science.
At specialist specialist numbers going up,
numbers going up.
One masterminds fascinated.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So the and I apologize for showing that to
you.
The crowd just has never seen anything this
funny.
This is again, it's the Reawaken America tour.
It's a right wing tour.
It's like a circus.
It goes around the country, and it's a combination
of anti-vax COVID denial.
I guess Christianity and conspiracy theories,
that's what it is.
And so there's a bunch of stuff here.
The hysterical crowd pointing and laughing
like it's just so it it's we've never seen
anything this funny.
Do these people literally not leave their
houses like, are you just
Speaker 2: watching paint dry all day that
Speaker 1: this is what makes you laugh?
It's very, very strange.
Or are you just so desperate for something
pretending to be comedy that makes fun of
the left to be funny that you are willing
to laugh at anything?
And then here's the hypocrisy, and I want
to make sure everybody understands this.
Jim Breuer laughed
Speaker 2: at science
Speaker 1: specialists numbers going up following
data when Jim Brewer's wife was sick
Speaker 2: with cancer.
He went on
Speaker 1: the radio and he was asked about
it.
I don't remember if it was Opie and Anthony
or one of those shows.
And he said, We are going to the best specialists.
Speaker 2: I mean, he he used the word
Speaker 1: in this clip.
He laughs at listening to
Speaker 2: specialists
Speaker 1: because it's covered when his wife
was sick.
He went to specialists who said We were going
to.
Speaker 2: We're finding the best specialists.
Speaker 1: We're looking at the
Speaker 2: research and the
Speaker 1: double blind, placebo controlled
trials, which we are now dismissing when it
comes to COVID.
We are looking at clinical trials.
Speaker 2: We are following the science.
Speaker 1: When it came down to his wife,
he wasn't doing this act.
He was going to the exact professionals and
trusting the exact system that he now ridicules.
You can find that segment if you look for
it.
I, Sirius XM is very litigious with copyright,
but you can find that segment.
So as usual,
Speaker 2: disgusting value going out there
and saying
Speaker 1: specialists, oh, well, Fauci, but
he doesn't even really appear to adhere to
those very values when the rubber meets the
road.
Gross.
And by the way, the right still can't do comedy.
Nothing has changed there, folks.
We'll have this clip up on our Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at David
Pakman show.
We'll take a quick break and be
right back.